Bienvenidos al segundo video de problemas
de aplicación relacionados con edades.
Aquí ya tenemos un problema escrito, veamos
qué es lo que nos está planteando.
Salman, o sea, yo, tiene 108 años de edad
y esto claramente es en el futuro, es ficción,
solo sucederá si cuido mi salud.
Así que Salman tiene 108 años de edad
y Jonathan tiene 24 años de edad.
¿En cuántos años la edad de Salman será exactamente 4 veces la edad de Jonathan?
Calculemos esto, supongamos que la variable "y"...
usemos ahora "y" en vez de "x"...
supongamos que "y" es años hasta que...
Sal, abreviemos Salman con Sal tenga...
4 veces la edad de Jonathan.
Bien si el día de hoy Sal yo, Salman...
chispas, es difícil referirse a uno mismo
en tercera persona...
pero si actualmente Sal tiene 108 años en "y" años más Sal va a tener 108 más "y",
esto va a ser la edad de Sal en "y"...en "y" años...
Dentro de "y" años Sal va a tener 108 más "y" años,
mientras que para Jonathan, es fácil de ver que va a tener 24 más "y" años,
24 más "y" va a ser Jon, voy a poner Jon
por Jonathan, en "y" años,
esa va a ser la edad de Jonathan en "y" años, 24 más "y".
¿Qué más nos dice el problema?
Nos preguntan, ¿en cuántos años la edad
de Salman será exactamente... vamos a subrayar
esto para enfatizarlo... exactamente 4 veces
la edad de Jonathan?
Y eso de exactamente es importante, pues actualmente la edad de Salman es más de 4 veces
la edad de Jonathan. Y lo que queremos calcular es
cuando va a ser exactamente 4 veces la
edad de Jonathan.
Tenemos entonces que en "y" años la
edad de Sal va a ser, 108 más "y"...
108 más "y" va a ser la edad de Sal y eso queremos que sea exactamente 4 veces,
4 por la edad de Jonathan, 24 más "y".
Y ahora simplemente resolvemos la ecuación.
Tenemos 108 más "y" es igual a 4 por 24 es...
4 por 25 es 100 menos 4 es 96 más "4y", despejamos
"y"... me voy a saltar algunos pasos pues
esto debe ser fácil para ti...
"3y" es igual a...
"3y" es igual a 108 menos 96, esto nos da
"3y" igual a 108 menos 96, es 12, ¿correcto?
Sí, "3y" es igual a 12, de donde "y" es igual a 4.
Así es que usando álgebra hemos obtenido
que en 4 años Salman va a tener exactamente
4 veces la edad de Jonathan.
Veamos si se cumple,
en 4 años Salman va a tener 112 años, mientras que Jonathan va a tener, 24 y 4 = 28, veamos entonces,
28 por 4, 8 por 4 = 32 y 80= 112.
Sí, efectivamente, nuestra respuesta es correcta.
Excelente, hagamos otro.
Uff... espero que no hayas oído eso,
es mi estómago gruñendo, trabajamos tan duro de este lado, que no me ha dado siquiera tiempo de ir a comer.
Muy bien, hagamos otro problema, pero ahora lo voy a escribir en verde. Veamos.
Raul tiene actualmente 5 veces la edad de Armando,
hace 85 años...
y este es realmente un intervalo de tiempo muy largo...
hace 85 años Raul tenía 10 veces
la edad de Armando
¿Qué edad tiene Armando actualmente?
Veamos cómo lo abordamos.
Me parece que es un problema muy interesante...
déjame hacer los ajustes de mi pluma...
vamos a proceder como en el primer video.
Hagamos para empezar una tabla.
Veamos entonces, nos están pidiendo la edad
de Armando actualmente,
así es que vamos a poner aquí Armando...
Armando...
y actualmente y también tenemos,
cual es el otro periodo de tiempo que se está considerando... hace 85 años...
hace 85 años...
una galaxia realmente lejana.
Muy bien, los protagonistas son Armando y
Raúl, lo que queremos encontrar es la edad
de Armando actualmente, así que vamos
a asignarle la variable "x".
Raúl tiene actualmente 5 veces la edad de
Armando, vamos a subrayar esto,
actualmente Raúl tiene 5 veces la edad de Armando, si
la edad e Armando es "x", la edad de Raúl
es 5 por "x", "5x", hace 85 años si actualmente
Armando tiene "x" años, entonces hace 85 años,
Armando tenía "x" menos 85, mientras
que Raúl que actualmente tiene "5x" años,
hace 85 años tenía "5x" menos 85, simplemente
he restado 85 años de las edades actuales
pues vamos 85 años hacia el pasado y también
tenemos esta información que aun no hemos
utilizado, nos dice que hace 85 años Raúl
tenía 10 veces la edad de Armando.
Así es que este número va a ser 10 veces
este otro número, eso es lo que nos están
dando con esta información, hace 85 años
que es esta situación, la edad de Raúl era
10 veces la edad de Armando, vamos a escribir
eso matemáticamente con una ecuación.
La edad de Raúl entonces era, "5x" menos
85, lo cual en ese momento era 10 veces
la edad de Armando, 10 que multiplica a "x" menos 85.
Y ahora simplemente resolvemos la ecuación,
tenemos que "5x" menos 85 es igual a "10x"
menos 850, despejamos "x", tenemos entonces...
voy a saltarme algunos pasos para confundirte...
"5x" es igual a... uff... creo que el que
se confundió fue otro...
a ver veamos...
"5x" es igual a 850 menos 85
y esto ¿a cuánto es igual?
850 menos 85 sería 35 menos de 800,
35 menos de 800 es "5x" es igual a 770, menos 5, 765,
obtenemos que "x" es igual a 765 entre 5,
hagamos la división, 7 entre 5 es 1, 1 por
5 = 5, restamos, nos queda 2, bajamos el 6,
26 entre 5 es 5, 5 por 5 = 25, restamos 25
nos queda 1, 15 entre 5 es igual a 3.
"x" es igual a 153.
Vaya que viven muchos años estos tipos,
hemos obtenido que Armando tiene 153
años de edad actualmente.
Veamos si esto es cierto.
Si Armando tiene 153, entonces Raúl...
espérame...
esto no puede ser...
aquí hay un error...
casi se me acaba el tiempo,
tengo que ver donde está el error...
a ver, veamos...
si Armando tiene 153, si Armando es "x", Raúl es "5x", eso hace sentido...
ahhh, ya vi, ya vi donde está mi error, yo
pensaba que Raúl era menor que Armando
y no podía ser...
no, no, no, Raúl es mayor que Armando
y Raúl tiene 5 veces la edad de Armando que es 765
años, vaya, vaya, podría ser Matusalén,
así es que Raúl tiene entonces 765 años
y si nos remontamos a hace 85 años,
entonces, ¿Raúl cuánto tenía?
Raúl tenía en ese entonces...
a ver, para no hacernos bolas, vamos a escribir
eso aquí, entonces tenemos que actualmente
Armando tiene, 153 años y Raúl, hemos obtenido
que Raúl tiene 765,
¿qué pasó hace 85 años?
Armando tenía 153 menos 85, ¿a cuánto es eso?
150 menos 80 es 70 y 2 = 72 años,
mientras que Raúl tenía 765 menos 85...
espera, esto no me está checando...
¿dónde me equivoqué?
Y solo me quedan 10 segundos...
No. Lo vas a tener que checar por tu cuenta,
vamos a terminar aquí este video.